[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday
march the 10th
my name is freddie gray i am the deputy
editor of the spectator and i will be
your host today
on the show this week
today we learned that the british
government has imposed sanctions on
roman abramovich the oligarch owner of
chelsea football club and ally of
vladimir putin
the foreign office has also set up a
special oligarch task force to deal with
the
political fallout of the crisis in
ukraine
i'll be talking to james forsyth our
political editor and katie balls our
deputy political editor about how
westminster is dealing with the crisis
next we'll be asking if vladimir putin
has made a grave strategic mistake in
invading ukraine what does that mean for
the future of europe
i will be talking to peter hitchins and
professor mike martin
about nato's response and how the
conflict is developing
and in this week's magazine the
spectator's russia correspondent owen
matthews writes a notebook about leaving
moscow i'll be talking to him about what
people are thinking and feeling within
russia
before we get going we'd like to say a
very special thank you to canaccord
genuity wealth management
can accord go above and beyond to offer
you
advice and guidance with your wealth
management just visit can do wealth dot
com for more information
first up war and politics the british
government has pleased some people by
announcing sanctions on roman abramovich
the owner of chelsea football club and
possibly the most famous russian
in britain
meanwhile priti patel has been
criticized for britain's refugee
processing policy and not knowing the
difference between lille and calais
i'm joined by our politics editor james
forsyth and our deputy politics editor
katie balls to discuss
james i'll start with you we we've heard
today that roman abramovich has been uh
sanctioned further sanctioned
um and this is the targeting of a very
prominent oligarch because uh he's very
particularly prominent in britain of
course because he owns chelsea football
club
are we in brisbane becoming a bit
obsessed with this one figure
i i think the
reason that he has become so significant
is that roman brownridge's
purchase of chelsea was became a whole
symbol of the arrival of russian money
in london
here they were they took uh what um
chelsea fans won't like this they took a
relatively minor football team and
propelled it to being the team that
dominated english football for several
years
and that was essentially because
of the money that abramovic brought to
the club and it was a symbol of how
russian money was changing british life
and so i think that is why there has
been such a tension on what was going to
happen to him in in terms of of
sanctions and i think from the
government's point of view you know
they've got one of the
i mean there have been two
weak points in terms of the government's
response to the ukraine crisis you know
one has been refugees which we might
touch on later but the other has been
the sanctioning of individuals where uh
it is quite clear that other
jurisdictions have uh moved more rapidly
than the uk has so while as the uk has
been very good on what one might call
systemic sanctions for example pushing
to cut russia a slew of russian banks
out of a swift international payment
system in terms of sanctioning
individuals the uk
has not done as well and i think you can
see a recognition of that implicitly in
the economic crime bill
which is going through parliament at the
moment which would which essentially
allows the uk to piggyback on sanctions
imposed on individuals by the us the eu
canada australia and other allies
casey there's a bit of concern in
britain that our politicians are uh so
obsessed with domestic stories domestic
headlines uh perhaps particularly the
sabramovich story that they aren't
really thinking about the strategy
against russia do you pick up on concern
about that within westminster
i mean i think there's general concern
which is the uk government wants to talk
very tough and you saw that over the
weekend with boris johnson in his six
point plan
um to defeat putin which was really
principles guiding principles more than
firm action
and i i think there is a sense amongst
mps that ultimately is all very well uh
welcoming zelensky the ukrainian and
leader to parliament to address via
vidya lincoln and applauding him but
actually the uk
does have some quite severe limits in
terms of how far it wants to go so
therefore how much can they really say
they're doing at some point uh are they
actually going to go further in terms of
their rhetoric than they're willing to
go in actions and and therefore i do
think there's concern on that point
which is just boris johnson clearly
wants to
look as though he's one of the main
leaders in this crisis but ultimately um
there are severe limits as to how much
he is really willing to do
james it's been noticeable in in russian
statements putin's statement and other
statements from the russian government
that they seem to single out britain
as a particularly
antagonistic force
is the government happy uh being put in
that role but by the russians do we want
to be seen
uh as the tip of nato's spirit at least
as far as rhetoric is concerned
so i think the uk has um
quite deliberately kind of moved ahead
of other countries in this crisis you
know it was providing lethal aid to
ukraine before the russians invaded you
know there are now 20 countries doing so
when the uk started it was one of a far
smaller group
the uk wants to say that it that it is
pushing for these greater systemic
sanctions it is arguing to go further it
is the only european country to have
announced a plan to ban uh the import of
russian oil um and so i think the uk
wishes to show
uh that that is that it is at the
forefront you know it sent has sent more
troops to reinforce nato's eastern flank
i think what i mean the uk strategic
view
is as follows one it wants to emphasize
to
uh the baltic states and eastern
european states you know the uk is the
uk is prepared to be a very active
defender of them as they face more
russian intimidation
and i think also the uk view is you know
look ultimately if putin is not stopped
at this point
you get into the the rules-based
international order will take a massive
blow makes it more likely that china
will move on taiwan and the world will
become ultimately a less secure and a
less prosperous place
there seems to be
moves now towards a negotiated
settlement
could britain find itself in a position
of cheering on war when peace is a is a
possibility
for talks in turkey today
i have made you know virtually no
progress i think if you look at lavrov
claiming that russia has not invaded
ukraine
i mean that tells you all you need to
know about the seriousness of the
russian negotiating position
i think the uk's view is this is that
the ukrainians should decide
what terms they are prepared to accept i
mean if you look at the uk's language it
is it is basically stressing but it
isn't prepared to see a deal imposed on
ukraine so essentially you know uh a
deal being done above ukraine's head
between the great powers and russia
and i think that the uk will stick to
that position and i think that you know
that is one of the reasons why the uk
and ukrainian governments are in such
close contact
i think there is a question here which
is you know yes
there is
you know
it is hard to see how this war does not
end in either a negotiated settlement or
a stalemate
and i think that one thing that the
intensity of ukrainian resistance has
done is it has made it quite clear that
russia's initial war aim of uh
knocking out the whole country and
installing a puppet government you know
that is no longer i think a credible aim
i think if you look at that at the
manner in which the ukrainians are
resisting now it is quite clear that the
russian military is not large enough to
hold the country in perpetuity and keep
a puppet regime in place
katie looking back on the on the sort of
domestic front uh there's obviously a
refugee crisis brewing uh pretty patel
is getting a lot of criticism today uh
for our handling of the looming refugee
crisis uh and she seems to have thought
that there was a refugee processing
center was going to be set up in calais
but it's in fact been set up in leo uh
do you think the christmas against her
are unfair
i think that when it comes to the
ministers who are receiving the most
praise i think figures such as ben
wallace are winning plaudits um whereas
i think priti patella is getting a lot
of criticism and and that is partly just
because there's been so much confusion
coming out of the home office about what
is going on i think when she uh wrote in
the sun over the weekend um about how um
you know there would be a route uh you
know for those who don't have family
members to come over and you know
promising more help it took some other
departments by surprise because there's
little coordination going on and so i
mean i think clearly you've got to hold
the home secretary responsible for uh
what's coming out their department so i
think that's clearly an issue i think
that it's not just opposition mps who
are frustrated i've spoken to ministers
who are really um
quite dismayed by the messages coming
out of the home office um but also
you're hearing boris johnson saying one
thing which is different to what pretty
patella is saying um there are lots of
people speculating that pretty patel
could be moved at the next reshuffle but
i think ultimately uh where this is more
is just in the immediate future um there
is a sense that the home office are
going to have to get act together and
they will also need to go further
actually in terms of the offer to
refugees um those ukrainians that do
want to come to the uk
there's been quite a lot of criticism of
uh liz trust too i mean uh she at the
start of the conflict she sort of
encouraged uh have a go heroes uh in
britain to go out and fight and and now
we have a situation where uh we seem to
have soldiers who are going who have
absconded to go and fight we don't know
where they are and there's a bit of a
panic about that
uh are there a lot of people in
westminster who think that liz trust has
been irresponsible with her rhetoric
yeah i mean i think that probably if
you're looking at the ministers who are
receiving the most criticism i think
pretty brutal is receiving very
widespread criticism from mps right now
i think in the case of liz trust the
foreign secretary um it's a little bit
more of a mixed bag i think the comments
you're referring to which is this idea
that um you know you could go and fight
if you wanted to um you've seen
snapdowns all across from that um i
think the fact that you had you know
senior defense figures out on the
weekend um thing that was something that
should not happen is clearly
embarrassing uh for the foreign
secretary you've also had the prime
minister say different uh lead to liz
trust as has the defense secretary ben
wallace so i think that istina is a big
mistake in terms of her handling um i
think that there are some things she's
done that have received praise such you
know actually being on the first
minister to talk about the fact that the
cost of living crisis is going to be
felt and that is something that will be
made worse by ukraine so boris doesn't
hasn't done um but clearly those
comments are quite hard to take back and
i think it has undermined uh some of her
performance so far
james i'll finish with you uh obviously
the energy crisis is kicking in uh
consumers british energy consumers are
about to hit about to face very very uh
serious rises in their bills
uh do you think the political support
for this war will start to wane quite
quickly
i think this is one of the big tests of
of the west the west have imposed these
very stringent very sweeping sanctions
on russia
if they are to be effective as a as a
form of deterrence in future the west
has got to show but it is prepared to
endure the economic pain that goes with
these sanctions and i mean that and you
know and that economic pain is going to
be quite substantial i think if if uh
the energy price cap rises to 3 000
pounds in october as you know which
seems at the moment a relatively
conservative estimate then you know i
find it quite hard to see how that
doesn't cause a recession given the
squeeze that would impose on on
household budgets so i think the west if
the west wants to use these sanctions as
it's kind of primary form of deterrence
and send a message to countries that if
you wish to try and seize territory by
force you know this is one of the ways
in which you will be punished the west
will have to show that it is prepared to
keep those sanctions in place and follow
through on them despite the fact they
cause economic pain now there are things
you can do in the margins like trying to
get hold of other supplies trying to
persuade some countries to pump more um
or to produce more energy but you know
though ultimately the west has to show
but it is prepared to accept the
economic pain that sanctions brings
imposes on those who are imposing the
sanctions
if they are to be effective
james and katie informative as ever
thank you very much indeed
next up as far as we understand the
russian military campaign in the ukraine
is not going
according to plan has putin made an
enormous mistake and if so what should
the west's response be
i'm joined now by dr mike martin who is
professor of war studies at king's
college london
and the mail on sunday sunday columnist
peter hitchens
mike i will start with you um
quite recently you tweeted
i'm going to call this i think the
russian armed forces are going to
collapse
followed by putin leaving power i can't
say this for certain obviously but i
think this is the eventuality can you
give us a bit of a breakdown uh as to
why you think that
i can um
the first question when you're launching
any kind of military action is to have
uh uh
um
your military resources matched up to
your strategic goals um putin's
strategic goal here requires about a
million troops the overthrow of the
ukrainian government and the replacement
replacement of it by someone more
favorable to russia um they've rolled up
with about 200 000 troops so completely
mismatched uh resources to their aims
that's the first thing the second thing
is as has become clear to absolutely
everybody
the russian army
is um
unable to do its own logistics unable to
repair its vehicles
um has plenty of desertions has
conscripts
and that's not to say that the
ukrainians are not also suffering losses
but the ukrainians are fighting on home
territory with the support of the
population and their morale is sky high
whereas the morale of the russians is
about as low as it can get i mean within
the last week they've lost two two-star
generals
um which means that something's going
very very wrong and all of those things
that i've described there morale
equipment and personnel are really what
makes up the fighting power um of a
military and if you look at the two
sides the ukrainians have got most of
the elements of the what make up the
fighting power of a military and the
russians don't
and so the question is what happens if
they do get routed in the field or they
get fought to a standstill and
effectively start getting picked off to
an even greater degree than they are now
well i think the problem is that putin
relies to a great degree
on succeeding in this and so if he fails
or at the extreme the russian military
gets routed as has happened in some
small skirmishes but if it happens at an
operational level in ukraine i think
putin stays a numbered
to what extent do you think our
perspective might be warped somewhat by
the fact that most of our information
that we're getting is coming from
ukrainian sources which are not always
altogether reliable
that's that's absolutely true
um and i think that if you look at for
example the
u.s
military's assessments of the situation
they seem to
let's just take casualties for instance
they say that the
russians have suffered between two and
four thousand casualties which by the
way is is much much more than the u.s
suffered in 20 years in afghanistan
they also say the ukrainians have
suffered approximately
similar numbers but come back to the
calculus the russians are
working at the end of their supply lines
in hostile terrain and the ukrainians
are operating on home grounds with i
mean it's a country of 44 million people
we have an armed forces of let's say 350
000 plus territorial defense units and
and so on and so forth um there is a
much more
the supply of labor for the ukrainians
is much greater than that um available
to the russians so even if it was a one
for one
um attrition rate um the ukrainians
would eventually win that mathematical
contest
peter uh let me bring you in we've heard
a fair bit in recent days about putin's
hubris how he's miscalculated greatly
are you beginning to get a bit concerned
that there's a little bit of western
hubris uh creeping into uh
the the the conversation
uh here well not so far i think i mean
the action by putin was plainly mad uh
and
was almost certainly
would have been opposed by almost all of
his closest advisors who have any sense
if he'd shared it with them uh it has
all the characteristics of of a flailing
last throw by somebody who's
lost all sense of reality and it's not
surprising if it goes wrong i don't know
how wrong it's gone or how
how wrong it will go partly because i
don't actually know what the actual
objective of the attack was supposed to
be in the first place i'd never be able
to work that out does he seriously want
to take the whole of ukraine and hold it
down how could he do that anyway the one
of the things which fascinates me is in
my
long arguments over the years with the
new cold war merchants who've been
saying we've got to be prepared for
russia to behave badly i've said over
and over again russia has an economy the
size of italy and its armed forces
aren't up to much
i would have thought that a large part
of my position has been demonstrated as
factual by this performance
it's it's not a first-rate army as far
as one can see
nor
as has been rightly said is it big
enough for for any of the tasks it might
have been set out to do so i thought
it's hubris on the other hand in general
uh it's always wise to stick to what you
actually know and i'm not at all sure we
actually know very much about this war
at all the amount of first-hand
reporting though heroic where it appears
it's very it's very small
and the the knowledge that we have i
don't know i've sorry i've been brought
out over the years not entirely to trust
intelligence service accounts of what's
going on wait see what really happens
but i don't i just don't think
uh that the the russia was ever powerful
enough uh to to to seize uh ukraine and
hold it and i don't think it is now and
i suspect that what we're discovering is
that its military forces are not that
good and have not improved all that much
from the time when they were that awful
bunch of drunks who who who pretty much
uh massacred everyone in chechnya so i
don't know but i i don't i don't think
it would necessarily be hubristic to say
judging on by their performance so far
they're not doing very well
were you surprised peter when i mean you
talked about intelligence being doubtful
uh it seemed that western intelligence
particularly american intelligence was
absolutely spot on
uh to certainly to my surprise about
putin's plans for invasion well exactly
and isn't that such a shock after all
the rubbish they've been talking for the
past 30 or 40 years over and over again
for them actually to get something right
you must forgive those of us you weren't
entirely convinced by it
it's not a thing that intelligence is
especially good at so yes
congratulations to them they got one
right let's see if they can keep it up
mike yesterday uh president vladimir
zelinsky was in spoke uh by video link
to the house of commons uh to uh sort of
rapturous applause um do you worry
perhaps that we are um
getting a little bit obviously we are on
ukraine's side but perhaps the the
political class in this country is
becoming a little bit blind as to the
reality because we're getting slightly
swept up
in cheerleading uh the ukrainian effort
um well i mean i don't think the
political class is up to much um in the
country at the moment
um i i think there's a there's a bigger
question about ukraine which is what's
the strategic outcome that we want we've
spoken plenty about what putin's
strategic games are
but it seems to me that
in the same way that putin wanted to
redesign the european security order so
do we actually the outcome that we want
from ukraine is
i think you know the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine being
respected of course but actually i think
we want a bit of a redesign of the
european security order and that
probably involves putin not being part
of that now how we achieve that goal
exactly how you apply leverage obviously
you know a change of leadership in
russia is an affair for the russians but
of course we can apply leverage to that
i think that that really must be
the outcome of this conflict and what is
more every action that the west that
nato that the us takes here is being
watched by china so we have to not only
solve the uh you know the global sorry
the sort of regional security challenge
here but we have to have an eye on the
global security architecture because
china will be looking very carefully at
what's going on here so this recent
fuffle over migs will they won't they
you know because someone said on twitter
as schrodinger's migs
that's watched by china and things are
interesting so if you do go in 10 days
later they'll be very unified for the
first 10 days and then they'll start
arguing over things like mix i think we
need to be very very very careful about
things like that there's a lot more than
ukraine at stake here we're talking not
just about the regional but also the
global security order and so we have to
get this right and i do worry that the
quality of leadership that we have at
the moment
specifically in the uk
probably is not able to think in big
picture terms and understand exactly how
to
influence the micro
by that i mean what's happening in
ukraine uh to achieve the grand
strategic outcomes that we want
peter what do you think the grand
strategic outcomes are
the ones that we want
well i don't know um
what i want and what um the united
states want for instance might be
different things but
the the thing is the the invasion has
changed everything now it's it
i think it's almost certainly made
putin's actual objective impossible
which is he had hoped to avoid the
implementation of the brzezinski
doctrine which is if you can take
ukraine away from russia russia becomes
permanently a minor power and this this
isn't a matter of territory it's a
matter really of who controls ukraine as
long as ukraine is not aligned uh things
bumped along on a relatively even keel
but since 2014 when
the west back to putch
in kiev and
installed the government which leaned
very sharply to the west russia has been
a state of panic about this which has
now come to full fruition
but by failing to do anything about it
in this this this mad spasm i think
probably just as as putin's actions in
uh particularly in the
lugansk and donetsk regions and the the
separation of the russian areas have
made ukraine more ukrainian uh this
attack on ukraine will make it far more
likely that ukraine will become a
permanent member of the of the western
security and economic structure and
there's no chance at all of russia being
able to win it back by diplomacy uh so
he's lost that battle and uh
those who wanted very much to pursue the
belittling of russia uh going right back
to
the wolfowitz doctrine of 1992 have got
their way uh the chances of russia ever
ever rising again is even a major
regional power are now pretty much done
for i think so we've got that and for
the rest of it i i would say that
it's a simple
summary of our wisest policy anybody's
wisest policy under these circumstances
don't interrupt your enemy while he's
making a mistake uh
it really and truly this is a colossal
mistake to start introducing no-fly
zones or or sending or sending polish
makes to ukraine under the circumstances
would be crazy thing to do
mike do you get the impression that i
mean there are certainly people uh in
the west who are
uh talking about the possible
involvement of poland uh there's been
all the talk about the sky and the
no-fly zone and all the various dangers
of that do you think there's a danger
that uh we will interrupt our enemy
while he's making a mistake and then
cause a much bigger and wider problem
yeah so here's the problem
um hundreds
if not thousands of ukrainian civilians
are dying as we speak and
i don't know
we might get to a point where a hundred
thousand ukrainians are dead within a
fairly short period of time ukrainian
civilians we've just seen
um a maternity hospital has been bombed
now
the problem is that grand strategy
doesn't actually care about such things
as reprehensible as that is and i know
that this is an unpopular view the
problem is that the
western politicians responding to
pundits and political pressure may
indeed do something stupid that is
counter to what their grand strategic
interests are and so to take some of
these examples you know no fly zone nuts
just work out exactly how to apply
leverage on russia without giving them
excuses to up the ante
poland getting involved over these migs
i mean the irony is the
the migs have a marginal at best uh
military
uh uh benefit you know very difficult to
get them over there and all the rest of
it like and marginal
far more useful would be a lorry load of
anti-tank missiles as we've seen right
all the russian convoys are strung out
having great great effect and you only
need one bloke or woman um
with an anti-tank missiles of course
absolute habit so far more useful and so
the only possible reason to do these
migs is to have a kind of political
signaling effect
and that would be some sort of uh
basically it sends a signal that we're
unified we're pulling together we're
swapping out migs for u.s f-16s we're
sending the mixed ukraine it sends this
kind of we are nato is unified signal to
russia but the way they've handled it is
sent exactly the opposite signal um so
we need you know and again i i sort of
worry this it comes back to i think a
quality of political leadership um
question um that i that i mentioned
earlier
peter if nato is invigorated uh is that
bad news
well i'm the wrong person to ask since
no i think you're the right person long
believe that nato should have been wound
up in 1991 and its continued existence
has been a menace uh i i i would say
that the these events predicted as they
were by by george kennan uh in 1998 uh
more or less and by jaeger gaidar the
russian liberal politician
and by many many other experts on
strategy said if you if you expand nato
if you push nato towards towards russia
you will cause the most terrible
problems and you will create in russia a
resurgence of revanchist opinion and uh
indeed by implication you will create
someone like vladimir putin well we've
done that now uh and as it happens it
appears that we might be going to get
away with it without too much terrible
damage i the point about the civilian
casualties is well made but my view is
that if you intensify war there will be
more of those casualties uh no fly zone
for instance would undoubtedly lead to
many many more casualties and almost
certainly beyond the borders of ukraine
any sort of widening of the war would be
likely to do that i i would very much
hope that we could we could
find at some stage fairly soon uh a way
in which we could end the slaughter
altogether the real danger is that is
that ukraine now slips into a condition
of permanent war uh that the russians
won't leave uh that no deal is done
that nobody wants to compromise
that all its major cities become
permanent fallujahs and people just die
and die and die and millions of people
have to become refugees perhaps for the
rest of their lives or corpses and what
would be the point of that i think there
has to be a moment at which we have to
consider what is the uh how how many
ukrainians were prepared to sacrifice
for the purposes of our of our pride uh
in refusing to make any kind of deal and
obviously in saying look you attacked
you're in the wrong uh but that doesn't
necessarily mean that we that we don't
desire peace for the human beings who
actually live in ukraine which i think
any any christian person does and any
civilized person does
may i respond to just some of peter's
points ready would that be okay yeah
yeah so on the question of nato
expansion
um
obviously we're all familiar with these
arguments but that presupposes that the
traditional buffer states if you like in
eastern europe the baltics poland
ukraine et cetera don't have a say in
the matter and quite clearly all of them
want to be part of nato they don't want
to be dominated by russia so this sort
of you know
yalta-esque napkin we're going to draw a
line and keep you guys buffer states
irrespective of whether you want to be
members of nato or the eu i think
undermines
one of the central planks if you like
that makes the west attractive which is
democracy people get to choose and so on
and so forth
um on the question of um
how many people in ukraine um need to
die
um
respectfully i'm not sure that that's a
question because
in the sense that
if if we don't get this right if we
don't get the security order right we
may well be sending
uh british people to die
and the you know
the question for our leaders um in
britain and their job of course is to
protect the interests of britain and
british people is that
we should we should not be getting
ourselves into situations where perhaps
british people are going to die
peter you respond to that well i
wouldn't disagree with that i'd be
appalled if if british
british military personnel got directly
involved in this and i at the moment i
could see no
cons possible justification for it going
back from out to the to the nato
question
if you really believe that then
presumably arguing for taiwan to be
given membership of nato which nobody
would do because it would be obviously a
stupid thing to do
as it happens we in the west don't even
recognize taiwan as a country let alone
allowed to join any alliances because
we're too scared of china the whole
history of nato expansion is that it was
not
the the idea was demanded by the the
nations involved is pretty slender uh it
was it was rammed through the senate uh
in the late 1990s by bill clinton and a
load of neocons and also with a huge
amount of very heavy lobbying by
american arms manufacturers this isn't
some sort of socialist worker stuff all
this was reported at the time by the new
york times about the same time that
you're george that i didn't interrupt
you about the same time that george
kennan came out of retirement to say for
heaven's sake don't do this stupid thing
the the the three baltic republics
gained their independence from from
russia in 1991
and they they did not enter nato for
several years
after that during which i know of no
material threat ever made to their
independence the whole thing that it was
demanded by these poor countries left in
limbo is pretty thin the truth that it
was very seriously warned against by
intelligent
highly pro-western uh strategists who
who thought that it was a foolish action
on our own account is beyond dispute i
can think of no other cause in history
that could conceivably unite noam
chomsky and henry kissinger but both of
them say that the expansion of nato is a
stupid thing to do and both of them
right
i'm so sorry i wasn't interrupting i was
actually saying i i was agreeing with
you at a time you can interrupt me to
agree with me that's okay in the future
but i didn't think
necessarily what you were going to do
people don't often do that
one very small point on taiwan um it's
the north atlantic treaty organization
so to
taiwan would be would be a bit crazy
will you say that
if i could just point out
sorry so it's a very important point
here i'm sorry if i hang on if i may
interrupt you um what we have seen
recently though um is actually we've
seen a slow edging towards the
integration of taiwan within an east
asian alliance system so we've actually
seen recently japan um who of course um
does have a
a pretty uh robust securities treaty
with the united states japan has
recently said that taiwanese um um
keeping taiwan separate from the
people's republic of china is in its
national security interest so it won't
have made those announcements without
first coordinating with the us and you
can start to see at almost world war one
esque chain of alliance systems in east
asia that although there isn't a nato
type structure actually we're starting
to get to the point now where with all
these alliances being triggered the us
is going to be dragged into a fight over
taiwan that's very heartening to know he
said sarcastically a first world war
system of alliances is what we really
need but uh by the point about taiwan
not being in the north atlantic would be
terrific if afghanistan were in the
north atlantic or if libya were in the
north atlantic but nato operations have
taken place in both those places and to
claim that it's limited to that area as
i'm afraid rather out of date there's
absolutely no reason why organization
that can put a force into afghanistan
couldn't incorporate taiwan
this this is a tremendous discussion uh
sadly i'm being told we have to wrap it
up i would i would actually like to uh
both uh ask you both uh a question i
mean
a sort of neat solution for a lot of
people as far as i can see it is that
putin is somehow removed or got rid of
one way or the other um can we be sure
mike and peter can we be sure that what
comes after putin uh would be better as
far as the west is concerned
no
absolutely not could be much worse there
all kinds of horrible things lurking in
moscow which could result from this
don't by any means be confident you're
going to get anything better
mike
and it's great because peter and i can
finish on agreement
we'll finish it there
thanks very much guys
while all this is going on it's hard to
get a sense of what is actually going on
inside russia but the spectator is very
lucky to have our russia correspondent
owen matthews who's written a brilliant
diary this week
about what how russians are thinking and
feeling about the conflict
owen joins me now
owen in your diary you use this phrase
repeatedly things fall apart
from the outside we're very much given
the impression from the news that russia
is being plunged into a deep economic
darkness
and as you suggest uh that seems to be
happening can you tell us a little bit
about your experience in moscow in in
the last few days
um
uh things fell apart freddie very
quickly and when they do um it's
it's extraordinary i mean it's it's it's
one of those one of the things that i've
actually experienced um
you know on many occasions um you know
during my career as a as a war
correspondent i've covered um six major
wars over the last 20 years and it's um
but i never expected to see it happening
in moscow and what's most scary is you
realize the sort of every element of
normality especially in russia which
you know basically doesn't really
produce very much except for you know
oil and gas as it turns out you know
just the sort of little nuts and bolts
of life just sort of fall out of and
eventually the whole edifice just sort
of crumbles into a sort of pile of
pieces
uh i mean you're just sort of banal
things like you know apple pay apple pay
cut off
russia you know you know your taxi app
doesn't work you know you can't order
food i mean moscow is a very
sophisticated uh extremely modern city
and in many ways it's like sort of
massively more functional than london
for instance
and you know the mcdonald's closed
announced on friday and uh that
announced yesterday that they were
closing you can't go to mcdonald's this
huge gigantic list of
companies that are refusing to
do business in russia you know
luxury shops closing you know adobe my
you know my colleagues you know adobe
wouldn't
wouldn't update um microsoft products
i'm not updating you know and um so i
mean obviously these are you know we're
talking sort of somewhat first world
problems you know people who you know
suddenly can't buy a uh you know their
sort of added ass sneakers or uh you
know do their update their professional
software um it's only a relatively small
proportion of people who are directly
affected by that but i mean for instance
if you take ikea
uh which closed last week i mean there
were massive crowds of people ikea is
you know pretty much
uh sort of middle class even lower
middle class in a place to shop ikea
closed you know that
it really feels very very bleak and
scary and also most importantly anyone
with money uh cannot um
transfer it out of the country and that
was one of the first things to go it was
the credit cards
the uh visa mastercard have pulled the
plug
a friend of mine a musketeer friend of
mine has
now paid two years of my schools of my
son's schooling in advance just because
his
his visa card is about from a russian
bank is about to expire and he was just
you know getting money out of his
account
uh in any way possible so
um it's very scary and it's very
terrifying that actually every element
of normality that the moscow middle
class took for granted is suddenly
disappearing they found out that it was
not theirs it was borrowed everything
was foreign nothing was russian and
russia
russian normality just disintegrates
when you take away everything foreign
and i think i'm right in saying that
russians can be quite cynical about the
west and uh
certainly they reckon that whereas
governments may sort of
grandstand against russia and so on
western companies uh will always want to
keep the money rolling in
they're now learning quite quickly
that's not necessarily the case do you
get the sense of surprise and shock
among them
uh well yes actually i mean
the um uh the the deputy head of united
russia who is uh which is of course
putin's party of power in the duma um
announced uh dave yesterday that um
uh
proposed day before yesterday uh a law
that would nationalize
i.e steel
the uh property of western companies
pulling out of russia because he claimed
they were doing it out of uh you know
political uh you know for political
reasons and um
that that's a very desperate
move but one thing this politician said
uh was you know uh it's like bees voting
against honey that was his first phrase
that he used about western companies uh
leaving the country and um i think
indeed you're absolutely right people um
many russians just assumed that you know
capitalists were only interested in
money but actually what we've seen is
they they're actually rather interested
and and very concerned about their
public image and and that's why so many
companies have have uh have pulled out
because there's been a sort of massive
social media media backlash against any
kind of company that's still doing
business in russia so it turns out that
actually you know for
the honey is not the number one thing
for the bees and
people and companies are willing to take
you know quite considerable economic
pain
shutting down automotive factories for
instance you know which volkswagen has a
huge
factory here in in in in moscow just
outside moscow and kaluga
you know that actually
uh they didn't expect um
the
sweeping united sanctions from western
governments
but the one thing that no one really
knew or anticipated is actually how
powerful private companies are and
private companies actually are the ones
that are really causing the pain and you
see that for instance in the aviation
sector like who knew that actually guess
what like you know
half of aeroflot's played 200 340 planes
are leased from international companies
most of the planes operated by
other private
uh moscow companies are leased
um a friend of a friend as a friend's
son was on a plane flying from moscow to
tel aviv they were these parents were
extremely relieved and delighted they
got them out of the country no
while the plane was in the air the pilot
announced like i'm sorry the leasing
company has cancelled the lease on our
plane we're gonna have to land refuel
and head back to moscow they never made
it out of russia and the very next day
all aviation stopped flying um to and
from russia and now the only way more or
less to get out is to fly to countries
like uzbekistan there are still
apparently friends of mine are getting
flies to tashkent you can get on a train
like it's 1917 again i mean russia has
never has not been closed
to this extent i might i can't imagine
really i mean not since the first days
of of of world war ii as has russia
being so absolutely shut off in the
world
what's interesting you say since world
war ii because i mean from your diary
one has a sense of what one imagines uh
the sort of worst periods of soviet rule
to be like uh
being sort of a a
a society where citizens have have no
autonomy and and kind of control of
their destiny and the fact that
retail capitalism uh uh sort of everyday
consumer capitalism has suddenly been
shut off does suggest that russia is now
back in
a kind of soviet dark age or is that
perhaps a bit trite
no no i i i think i mean lots lots of
russians are saying like you know that
when you were back in north korea uh but
the but but the more profound point is
um does that bother putin is that bad
for putin actually um i think in many
ways it's strangely enough suits putin
because yeah um in many
what we've seen over the last couple of
weeks is a total collapse essentially of
all the progress russia really made
towards capitalism and democracy over
the last
20 years of
the existence of the 30 years of the
existence of of of
post-soviet russia i mean it's you know
it's that dramatic
and suddenly all of the um sort of
the last vestiges of protest
um last vestiges of the free press like
just gone with the wind it's just like
over
you know people are now just being sort
of thrown in jail people and you know
getting knocks on their doors in the
night because they've been picked up by
facial recognition software
demonstrations i mean it's gone full
police state
and as for the um the class of people
who
are really bothered by
the
closure of um all of these shops and the
fact that they can't update their adobe
people like that actually tend to be um
um the international russians who are
used to foreign travel and foreign
clothes and you know skipping around the
world and spending money in in milan and
so on those people sort of actually many
of them tend to be rather skeptical of
putin anyway so i think putin doesn't
really care about them it's like good
riddance
you know we are willing to do it on our
own is his message and it's the message
of his government propaganda um the real
question is you know how deep does that
resentment go i mean how many people are
really willing to get on board with that
program of sort of belt tightening and
you know we are willing to you know we
are russians we are hard as nails and we
will tolerate everything in the in the
name of you know
when when our motherland calls us
um
uh i'm i'm not sure because uh how long
that's uh or how how deep that
resentment is gonna go and much less i'm
not uh and much less am i sure that it's
actually gonna
lead eventually to a sort of 1917 or
1991 revolutionary situation that we
still don't know whether that's going to
happen or whether that's likely
we see this letter zed uh which is
adored on on russian military vehicles
and has now become a sort of crusading
symbol for for russians who support
putin um did you see a lot of the zed
everywhere as a kind of revolutionary
symbol for what putin is trying to do
well actually um the um i did i did in
fact see one guy wearing a zed t-shirt i
mean
things move so fast i mean uh people
have not quite had the time to update
their wardrobes but um indeed the the
the the zed symbol only went
it became a meme and of course um
then it became um
the russia today of all people started
to produce the first zed t-shirts it's
like sort of painted said this letter
does not exist in russian um
um so the uh um yes and in fact the uh
the the the russian athlete that has now
been suspended after wearing his zed
symbol uh having lost to a ukrainian uh
in the uh in the in the olympics uh is
now sort of big national hero so um
the um
the in in russia when zed and if you add
an a to it it means means for i am for
the war
so actually be the t-shirt says zed za
for the war uh and of course there's a
counter meme which has been produced
which is
if you add those three letters to zed it
means what for
so actually sort of people are there
there's there's a sort of battle of the
zeds are you like a zed za or a zed zach
person um
so um indeed and it's become
a rallying cry for um russians who are
in favor of the war who as far as we can
tell suddenly from official polling
remain in a vast majority
i'm sorry is there a report
well they are in a vast majority but
there does seem to be uh perhaps a more
middle class internationalist uh russian
population
that are
that find themselves
perhaps at odds with the state more
dramatically at odds with the state than
they did before and these people are
being arrested already i mean one
wonders
does russia have the capacity to arrest
so many of its population well you'd be
surprised i mean you know um
the the stalin did pretty well i mean
the the the estimation by an apple bam
is is is that is it something something
like uh in the history of the of the
gulag some some four and a half million
people went through it so i mean you
know the the russian russians are quite
resourceful in that sense when it comes
to imprisoning incarcerating their own
people i mean obviously it's a slightly
facile and and uh not uh completely
accurate um
parallel to you know the darkest days of
stalin's oppressions but i mean it's
it's certainly going in there in that
direction and
um my son who
was in moscow on his gap year
and working in the theater and
has been was going to protests
and it was on lots of whatsapp groups
and telegraph groups um of young people
which they set up you know to check that
everyone's okay and it's just you know
the message has just been pouring in um
on those and also on various telegram
news channels of like all in his his
friends his acquaintances getting
arrested where they are
where uh um you know what they're being
charged with because that's very
important because some charges are
relatively minor some charges just
brought in this last week
carrying up to 15 years in prison for
instance for the
the new crime of spreading false
information
about uh military operations in ukraine
so uh
the uh um yes i mean sort of swathes of
young people are being gathered up it's
insanely brave of them
to even try um and the
however the protests that i saw uh in
moscow were really pretty tiny pretty
you know pathetic um
you know uh clearly
um it's deeply impressive that people
will risk certain er pretty much certain
arrests by going there
so clearly you know the the the the size
of demonstrations doesn't necessarily
reflect the size of of of the skepticism
or the opposition just because they are
so insanely heavily policed and the
penalties are so very very drastic
um
um
the the the real question is whether
that's going to spread because um
already we have you know some signs that
it's sort of going down the class system
there was a um
a local governor in uh another question
i believe in siberia
who was um who was filmed
who had a public meeting uh and
you know women soldiers mothers were
shouting got up and shouting like why
are our boys being sent to ukraine and
they were told it was a training
exercise and now i know that they're
neutral in ukraine you know that sort of
you know ordinary provincial grassroots
you know regular people not sort of
moscow hipsters but actually just sort
of regular siberians and the
and the distribution of the protest has
also actually been surprisingly big it's
not as surprisingly wide i should say i
mean
um it's not just muslims and petersburg
it's actually like in in over 40
provincial cities have
had demonstrations
putin and the the russian government
seem to have expressed particular
disgust at britain
uh and the role of the british
government
um in this conflict is that something
you've got a sense uh that is shared
more widely among
russians uh yes i mean i i i britain has
been a real bogeyman for russia um
largely because um i mean it's sort of
slightly it's
sort of somewhat
um political displacement because they
believe themselves in some sort of weird
fantasy land that russia is still like
the equal and sort of superpower peer of
the united states i mean i think that's
not true in any
fundamental sense except for one which
is that
russia is the only country that has
nuclear weapons parity with the united
states but in every other sense that's
you know clearly not true um russia's
economy is actually smaller than south
korea's
but the um uh
uh
the relationship between russia and
america is the object of you know
summits and so on and they think that
and and that sort of varies somewhat but
actually
in their relationship with britain they
really don't care because britain
doesn't really count for anything um
sadly um certainly in the view of
russians so therefore that's just sort
of a constant boogie man like you know
britain is you know just you know the
enemy of russia
but unfortunately that has has some some
practical and very scary consequences
because um
a uh an old friend and colleague um uh
who i probably shouldn't name but he uh
um who who i met up with in istanbul
that
um
he had also just escaped having um
having been intimidated um
basically menaced in his local
supermarket by a gang of uh
you know of goons of secret policemen
playing clothes policemen who obviously
from the fsb and their intention was
obviously to send him a message and a
warning and um you know sitting
on a
sort of windy beautiful terrace in
galata with uh with my friend um in
istanbul 102 years after the last major
russian immigration to istanbul in 1920.
uh we were sort of swapping stories
about who's going to you know who who
who remained who got out where everyone
was going and
but most importantly he said um you know
basically to the russian state um
we are at war the russian state
considers itself to be at war with
britain
finally owen do you think uh you will
ever go back it doesn't sound like
british tourists are going to be welcome
in moscow anytime soon do you do you see
yourself going back there
uh yes
certainly i mean i've got you know um a
flat
yeah i i i would like to get back very
much um the only um
[Music]
the uh the issue is whether whether
foreign writers and journalists actually
um are able to operate freely i mean
there was uh the press corps was already
the western press school was already
pretty small i think everyone's
extremely nervous because um they um
this new law about spreading false
information um about the um about the
military operation
um is um
which carries a 15-year prison sentence
sentence as i mentioned and that's
really yet to be tested does it apply to
the foreign press i mean it would
obviously be incredibly terrifying if
that were the case um i'm slightly
hopeful because you know even during
stalingrad and even in the darkest days
of the cold war uh there were still
always foreign correspondence in moscow
i mean they were they were followed they
were harassed they were the the freedom
of movement was very limited and so on
but you know nonetheless
rather like diplomats foreign
correspondents were basically allowed to
write what they uh what they wanted uh
although um the soviet state tried to
shape the narrative and
and what they're allowed to see and who
they're allowed to speak to so maybe
we'll go back to that but nonetheless
that means that you know we will be able
to
to work but um the the the
the
the jury's out i mean the the my
colleagues who stay there are
very brave as i've mentioned already one
of them has fled from you know kgb from
fsb intimidation
well from a purely selfish point of view
and i do hope you get back soon so we
can have
uh more great pieces from from russia
from you um thanks very much coming on
that is all for this week on the week in
60 minutes we would like to thank our
sponsors once again canaccord genuity
wealth management they give you the
expertise to build your wealth portfolio
with confidence
just visit can do wealth dot com for
more information
thank you very much and goodbye
[Music]
you